Is your Python code running a little slow?
Did you know the PyPy runtime could make it run up to 10 times faster?
Seriously.
Maja Falkowski is here to tell us all about it.
This is episode number 21, recorded Wednesday, July 8th, 2015.
Developers, developers, developers, developers.
I'm a developer in many senses of the word because I make these applications, but I also
use these verbs to make this music.
I construct it line by line, just like when I'm coding another software design.
In both cases, it's about design patterns.
Anyone can get the job done.
It's the execution that matters.
I have many interests.
Welcome to Talk Python To Me, a weekly podcast on Python, the language, the libraries, the
ecosystem, and the personalities.
This is your host, Michael Kennedy.
Follow me on Twitter, where I'm @mkennedy.
Keep up with the show and listen to past episodes at talkpython.fm.
And follow the show on Twitter via at talkpython.
This episode, we'll be talking with Maja Falkowski about the amazing alternative Python implementation,
PyPy.
This episode is brought to you by Hired and Codeship.
Thank them for supporting the show via Twitter, where they're at hired underscore HQ,
and at codechip.
Before we get to Maja, let me share a little news with you.
First off, Talk Python To Me has a new domain name, talkpython.fm.
I put the idea of a shorter .fm-based domain out on Twitter, and I'd say about 80% of the
listeners said they liked it better than the longer .com domain.
So here you go.
About a month ago, I moved all the MP3 file traffic out of Amazon S3 and into a dedicated
audio file cache server.
It's a lightweight Flask Python 3 app running through Nginx and Microwiskey.
A few listeners expressed interest in seeing the code, so I did a little work to try to generalize
this a bit, and I open sourced it.
I'm calling the project Cachedier.
And you can find a blog post as well as a link to the GitHub project on the show notes.
Next up, we have a new Python podcast.
I'm super happy to announce a Python podcast by Brian Okken called Python Test Podcast.
You can find it at pythontesting.net slash category slash podcast.
Now, let's get on to the show.
Maja, welcome to the show.
Thanks for inviting me.
Yeah, I'm super excited to talk about our topic today, which is PyPy.
And I think what you guys are doing with PyPy is so incredibly cool to be taking some of
these JIT compilation GC sort of semi-compiled languages or concepts and applying them to
Python.
So really happy to talk about that.
The story of compiling dynamic languages is really sort of old and half-forgotten.
Like, we know these days that you can do this with JavaScript, but the original work on small
talk dates back to at least mid-90s, if not earlier, which is what we are all building on
top of anyway.
So it's nothing new.
The new part is just applying this to Python.
That's right.
Well, I think it's great.
Maybe before we get into the details of what you guys are doing, maybe you could give the
listeners who are not familiar with PyPy a little history and introduction to it.
So PyPy is essentially a Python interpreter, which works very, very similarly to the normal
thing that you would call Python, that technically is called CPython.
It's a Python interpreter written in C.
And we have a different Python interpreter, which is implemented slightly differently.
And for the most part, glancing over all the details, it should run faster on most of the
examples because it can dynamically compile Python down all the way to the assembler level.
So it's like a normal Python interpreter, except sometimes faster, most times faster, in fact.
That's it.
It sounds very simple, but it's actually quite a big project.
It has been around more or less 10 years by now.
Wow.
It started 10 years ago.
And when did you get involved with it?
I got involved, I think, 2006 or 2007.
I was doing, I sort of got interested in Python static analysis, which PyPy, part of PyPy is doing
that, is taking a restricted subset of Python, which PyPy is implemented in and compiling it
down to the C level.
So I was interested in Python static analysis and I glanced over PyPy project and sort of
started getting involved.
And then I got a spot at Google Summer of Code to work on PyPy for the summer.
And that's essentially how it all started.
How many people work on PyPy or contribute to PyPy?
Depending how you count, it's anything between three and 30.
PyPy is a big umbrella project for a vast variety of anything from, as I said, a Python interpreter
to very researchy stuff that people at various universities try to experiment with.
Like there is a couple of people working on running Python and PHP in the same process.
So you run PHP code in the server, but you can still call Python functions in that process.
There are people working on software transactional memory.
So it's a big umbrella project that is a research vehicle for a lot of people, additionally to
being the Python interpreter.
Yeah, I can see how that would work for if you're doing some sort of academic research,
especially something with JIT and GC, then it makes a lot of sense.
I think one of the things that people either who are new to Python or have kind of dabbled
in it, but are not, you know, deeply working with it and thinking about the internals of
it every day, don't realize that there's actually a whole variety of different interpreters out
there.
There's a bunch.
They're all slightly different.
So let's glance over them because I think it's important to know there's like the CPython is
the normal Python interpreter that is probably used by 99% of people using Python.
Yeah.
If I open up Linux or my Mac and I type the word Python and enter that's CPython, right?
That's CPython.
So that's what most people would use.
CPython internals that you need to know is the fact that it's implemented in C.
And another internal detail that's important to know is that it exposes the C API, which
goes quite low.
So it's possible to write C extensions in C for Python.
So you write a bunch of C code, use a special API for accessing Python objects, and then it
can be called from Python code, your C functions.
Then we have Jiton, which is quite old, actually.
And it's a Python interpreter written in Java and a similar project called Iron Python, which
is a Python interpreter written in C#.
And those two interpreters, they're quite widely used for people who write Java and want a better
language.
So they, so their main big advantage is integration with the underlying platform.
So Jiton is very well integrated with Java and Iron Python with C#.
So if you're writing C#, but you would really love to write some Python, you can do that these
days.
And then there's PyPy, which is another Python interpreter written slightly differently with
a just-in-time compiler.
So those are the four main interpreters.
And there is, there is quite a few projects that try to enter this space, like PyStone, which
is another Python interpreter written by Dropbox people.
Yeah.
I wanted to ask you about PyStone because that's, that seems to me to be somewhat similar to
what you guys are doing.
And, and it comes, the fact that it comes from Dropbox where Guido is and a lot, there's a
lot of sort of gravity for the Python world at Dropbox that made it more interesting to me.
Do you know anything about it or can you speak to how it compares or the goals or anything
like that?
So, well, I know that it's very, very similar to the project that once existed at Google
called Unladen Swallow.
So the main idea is that it's a Python interpreter that contains a just-in-time compiler that uses
LLVM as the underlying assembler platform.
Let's call it that way.
And this is the main goal.
The main goal is to run fast.
Now, the current status is that it doesn't run fast.
That's for sure.
It runs roughly at the same speed as CPython for stuff that I've seen on their website.
As for the future, I don't know.
I really think the future is really hard.
Especially when you don't have much visibility into it, right?
Yeah.
Like, I can tell you that like PyPy, PyPy has a bunch of different problems to PyStone.
So, for example, we consciously choose to not implement the C API at first because the
C API ties you a lot into the CPython model.
We choose not to implement it at first.
We implement it later as a compatibility layer.
So the first problem is that it's quite slow.
It's far, far slower than the one in CPython.
And as far as I know, right now, Dropbox uses the same C API, which gives you a lot of problems,
like a lot of constraints of your design.
But also, like, gives you a huge, huge benefit, which is being able to use the same C modules, which are a huge part of the Python ecosystem.
Yeah, especially some of the really powerful ones that people don't want to live without, things like NumPy and, to a lesser degree, SQLAlchemy, the things that have the C extensions that are really popular as well.
So you guys don't want to miss out on that, right?
Right.
So you brought two interesting examples.
So, for example, NumPy is so tied to the C API that it's very hard to avoid.
It's not just NumPy.
It's the entire ecosystem.
We, in PyPy, we re-implemented most of NumPy, but we are still missing out on the entire ecosystem.
And we have some stories how to approach that problem, but it's a hard problem to tackle, that we choose to make harder by not implementing the C API.
However, for example, the SQLAlchemy stuff.
SQLAlchemy is Python.
It's not C, but it uses the database drivers, which are implemented in C, like a lot of them.
So our answer to that is CFFI, which is a very, very simple way to call C from Python.
And CFFI took off like crazy.
Like, for most things, like database drivers, there's a CFFI-ready replacement that works as well and usually a lot better on PyPy that made it possible to use PyPy in places where you would normally not be able to do that.
And CFFI is like really, really popular.
It gets like over a million downloads a month, which is quite crazy.
And CFFI is not just a PyPy thing.
It also works in CPython, right?
Yeah, it works in CPython in between like 2.6 and 3.something, I think.
3.whatever is the latest.
And it works on both PyPy and PyPy3.
And since it's so simple, it will probably work one day in JITON too.
You said you have a plan for the NumPy story and these other heavy sort of C-based ones.
Currently, the way you support it, this is a question I don't know, is that you've kind of re-implemented a lot of it in Python?
So we, to be precise, we re-implemented a lot of it in our Python.
Our Python is the internal language that we use in PyPy.
Right, that's the restricted Python that you guys actually target, right?
Yes.
Yeah, but we don't, generally don't encourage anybody to use it.
Unless you're writing interpreters, then it's great.
But if you're not writing interpreters, it's an awful language.
But we, so the problem with NumPy is that NumPy ties so closely that we added special support in the JIT for parts of it and things like that, that we decided are important enough that you want to have them implement in the core of PyPy.
So we have, most of NumPy actually works on PyPy.
And this is sometimes not good enough because if you're using NumPy, chances are you're using SciPy, Scikit, Learn, Matplotlib, and all this stuff.
We have some story how to use it, which is to, the simplest thing is just to embed the Python interpreter inside PyPy and call it using CFFI.
It's a great hack.
It works for us.
Really?
You can like fall back to regular Cpython within your PyPy app?
Yeah, it's called PyMetabiosis.
That's awesome.
I'm pretty sure there's at least one video online with the author talking about it.
It works great for the numeric stack, which is its goal.
So this is our story.
We are still raising funds to finish implementing NumPy.
It says a very, very long tale of features.
And once we are done with NumPy, we'll try to improve the story of calling other numeric libraries on top of PyPy to be able to mostly seamlessly be able to use stuff like SciPy and Matplotlib.
It will still take a while.
I'm not even willing to give an estimate.
Sure.
But it's great.
And it does look like there's a lot of support there.
We'll talk about that stuff in a little bit because I definitely want to call attention to that and let people know how they can help out.
Before we get into those kind of details, though, can we talk just briefly about why would I use PyPy or when and why would I use PyPy over, say, CPython or Jython?
Like, what do you guys excel at?
When should a person out there is thinking, like, they've just realized, oh, my gosh, there's more than one interpreter?
How do I choose?
Like, can you help give some guidance around that?
So typically, if you just discovered, oh, there's more than one interpreter, you just want to use CPython.
That's like the simplest answer.
You want to use CPython, but if you're writing an open source library, you want to support PyPy at least, which is what most people are doing.
They're using CPython and the libraries support PyPy for the most part.
Our typical user, and this is a very terrible description, but this is our typical user.
This episode is brought to you by Hired.
Hired is a two-sided, curated marketplace that connects the world's knowledge workers to the best opportunities.
Each offer you receive has salary and equity presented right up front, and you can view the offers to accept or reject them before you even talk to the company.
Typically, candidates receive five or more offers in just the first week, and there are no obligations, ever.
Sounds pretty awesome, doesn't it?
Well, did I mention there's a signing bonus?
Everyone who accepts a job from Hired gets a $2,000 signing bonus, and as Talk Python listeners, it gets way sweeter.
Use the link Hired.com slash Talk Python To Me, and Hired will double the signing bonus to $4,000.
Opportunity's knocking.
Visit Hired.com slash Talk Python To Me and answer the call.
You have a large Python application that's spanning servers, serving millions of users,
and you're running into corners.
Like, you can't serve requests quickly enough.
You can't serve enough users from machine.
You're running into problems.
Now, your application is too big to, say, rewrite it in C or Go, or it's just, like, too scary for whatever reason.
So, you look, like, what it would take to run stuff in PyPy.
It usually takes, like, a bit of, your code should run, but it usually takes a bit of effort to, like, see what sort of libraries do you use.
Do you use NSE extensions?
If their C extensions are, like, crucial, can you replace them with something?
So, yeah, this is our typical user.
And I have people, I run a consulting company that does that.
There are people coming and asking, like, okay, I have this set up.
It's impossible to do anything with it now.
Can I just, like, swap the interpreters, make it run faster, and make the problems go away?
This is our typical user.
I hear why you described it that way is maybe not the best way, but, you know, you're right.
If you have 100,000, half a million lines of Python, and really you just need to make it a little faster.
If switching to a different interpreter like PyPy will solve that, that's great.
So, speaking of faster, can you talk about the performance comparisons?
I have a little example I'll tell you, but I'll let you go first.
So, as usual, performance comparisons are usually very hard to do and flawed.
Everybody, yes, absolutely.
Everybody's thing they care about is not exactly what you're measuring, and so it might be totally misleading.
But give it a shot.
One good estimate is if you don't have benchmarks, you don't care about performance.
Like, if you never wrote benchmarks for your applications, then chances are you don't actually care all that much.
And you shouldn't really...
That's the first step.
Like, make sure you know how fast your applications run.
Once you know that, you can measure it on different interpreters.
But as far as expectations go, PyPy tends to run heavy computations a lot faster.
Like, a lot is anything between 10 and 100 times faster, depending on the workload.
For stuff that's more...
And again, what is a typical Python program?
Typical Python program is probably Hello World.
How fast Python runs Hello World.
Roughly at the same speed as CPython, you won't notice.
But for a typical web application, the speed up, if you're not heavily relying on C extensions, would be around 2x.
So, 2x faster for a lot of people makes a lot of difference.
Absolutely.
It also depends on where are you waiting.
Like you said, you should profile it and figure this out.
If your Python web app is slow because 80% of the time you're waiting on the database, well, it doesn't really matter how fast your Python code is.
Your database is a problem.
Or something like this, right?
Exactly.
And like, the thing is like, so let's narrow it down to, say, web applications.
Like, okay, let me first talk about other stuff and then let's go to web applications.
Like, where people found Piper incredibly useful is things like high-frequency trading.
Like, not the very crazy high-frequency where you have to make decisions like multiple times per millisecond.
But like the sort of frequency where you want to make decisions within a few milliseconds.
And then those decisions are like tens of milliseconds.
Those decisions can, then you want to be able to modify your algorithms fast, which is a lot easier on Python than, say, on C++.
And you're running into less problems with how to shoot yourself in the foot and segfault all your trading.
So, that's when people tend to use Piper because like, in this sort of scenario, it would be like 10 times faster.
So, super low latency stuff where 10 milliseconds makes a huge difference to you.
Something like that.
Yeah.
Okay.
Another example is there's, for example, a project called MyHDL, which is the hardware emulation layer.
And these tend to emit sort of low-level Python code that just do computations to emulate hardware.
And then again, on Piper, it's like over 10 times faster.
So, those are the very good examples.
The very bad examples, as you said.
If your program, if your staff is waiting on the database, then you're out of luck.
Like, no matter how fast your interpreter responds.
But yeah.
On the typical web server load, even if there is such a thing, it would be around two times speed up.
Sometimes more, sometimes less.
Depending on the setup, really.
But as I said, you should really measure yourself.
The things where Python is quite better, if you spend most of the time in C extensions,
then it's either not helping or actually prevent you from doing so.
And the second time where it's not that great is when the program is short running.
So, because it's just-in-time compilation, it means that each time you run your program,
the interpreter has to look what's going on, pick things to compile to Assembler, compile them to Assembler,
and that all takes time.
Right.
There's a little more initial startup when that happens.
Yeah, the warm-up time is usually quite bad.
Well, I like to think that warm-up time of PyPy is quite bad.
And then I look at Java, when it's absolutely outrageous.
It's a relative statement.
It's a relative term.
Like, compared to CPython, PyPy time is really terrible.
And compared to Luach, it's, again, the warm-up time is terrible.
But compared to Java, it's not that bad.
So, yeah, it really depends on your setup.
And it's typically important for long-running applications.
Then again, this is a typical PyPy user.
When stuff like server-based applications where your programs run for a long time.
Right.
You start it up and it's going to serve a million requests an hour until it gets recycled or something, yeah?
Something like that.
I mean, these days, even JavaScript is long-running up.
Like, how long do you keep your Gmail open?
For usually, for longer than a few seconds.
Yeah, that's for sure.
So, let's talk a little bit about the internals.
Could you describe just a little bit of...
So, if I take a Python script and it's got some classes and some functions and they're calling each other and so on.
What does it look like in terms of what's happening when that code runs?
Okay.
So, I'll maybe start from, like, how PyPy is built and then get back to your question directly.
Yeah, great.
So, PyPy is two things.
And it has been very confusing because we've been calling them PyPy and PyPy.
And calling two things which are related but not identical the same name is absolutely terrible.
We'll probably fix that at some point.
But, like, PyPy is mostly two things.
So, one thing is a Python interpreter.
And the other thing is a part that I would call RPython, which is a language for writing interpreters.
It tends to be similar to Python in a sense that it's a restricted subset of Python.
But this is largely irrelevant for the architectural question.
So, you have an interpreter written in RPython that can be PyPy.
We have a whole variety.
There's Hippie, which is a PHP interpreter.
There's a bunch of Scheme interpreters.
And there's even a Prolog interpreter and a whole bunch of other interpreters written in RPython.
And then...
Is RPython a compiled language?
Yes.
And the other part is essentially the translation toolchain or a compiler for RPython.
So, it contains various things like garbage collector implementation for RPython,
the data types like strings, unicodes, and all the things that RPython supports.
It also contains a just-in-time compiler for RPython and for interpreters written in RPython,
which is one level in direction compared to what you usually do.
So, the just-in-time compiler would be sort of generated from your RPython interpreter and not implemented directly,
which is very, very important for us because Python, despite looking simple,
is actually an incredibly complicated language.
If you're trying to encode all the descriptor protocol or how actually functions and parameters are called,
chances are you'll make a mistake.
So, if you're implementing an interpreter and a just-in-time compiler,
it's very, very hard to get all the details right.
So, we implement the Python semantics once in the Python interpreter,
and then it gets either directly executed or compiled to assembly.
So, if you're coming back to your question,
if you have a Python program,
first, what it does, it will compile to bytecode,
and bytecode is quite high level.
There's a thing called this module,
which you can just call this.this on any sort of Python object,
and it will display bytecode.
And the basic idea, which is what CPython does,
and which is what PyPy does too at first,
is to take bytecodes one by one,
look what's it,
and then execute it.
Yeah.
And is that like what's in the PyCache folders and things like that?
Like those PYC files?
Yeah.
The PYC files are essentially a serialized version of Python bytecode.
Okay.
It's just a cache to store to not have to parse Python files
each time you import a giant project.
Right.
Okay.
And so then CPython takes those instructions
and executes them via an interpreter,
but that's not what happens on PyPy, right?
That's what happens on PyPy initially.
So, all your code will be like executed like CPython,
except if you hit a magic number of like function calls
or loop iterations,
I think it's 1037 for loop iterations,
then you compile this particular loop,
in fact, this particular execution of a loop,
into assembler code.
Then if you have a mix of interpreter code
and assembler code,
and if you,
the assembler code is a linear sequence of instructions
that contains so-called guards.
So, the guards will be anything from
if something in the Python source
to is the type of this thing stays the same.
Then if you happen to fail those guards,
then you,
okay, I failed this guard,
I'm going to go and start compiling assembler again.
I mean,
at first you jump back to the interpreter,
but if you,
again,
hit a magic number,
you compile the assembler again from this guard.
And then you end up with like a tree of execution
that resembles
both your Python code
and the type structure
that you're passing in a few other things
that are automatically determined.
So,
at the end of the day,
you end up with a Python function
or like multiple Python functions
that got compiled to assembler
if you warm stuff for long enough.
Okay.
That's,
that is super interesting.
I didn't expect that it would have
this initial non-assembled assembler version.
That's,
that's very cool.
What was,
do you know what the thinking around that was?
Is it just better performance?
So,
there's a variety of things.
Like,
one thing is that if you try to,
to compile everything like upfront,
it would take you forever.
But also you are,
you can do some optimizations.
Like,
a lot of optimizations done in PyPy
are sort of optimistic.
Like,
we're going to assume special things like
sys.setTrace
or sys.getFrame
just does not happen.
And until it doesn't happen,
things can run nicely and smoothly.
But you're trying to figure out
on the fly
what's going on.
And then you compile pieces
that you know about.
So,
at the moment when you are compiling
a Python loop
or a function
or something like that,
you tend to know more
about the,
the state of execution
than,
that is just in the source.
Like,
you tend to know
the types,
the precise shape of objects.
Like,
is this an object
that's class X
and has two attributes A and B?
Or is it an object of class X
that has three attributes A, B, and C?
And those decisions
can lead to better performance,
essentially.
So,
on your website,
you say that this,
that PyPy may be better
in terms of memory usage as well.
How does that work?
It's a trade-off, right?
So,
first of all,
PyPy does
consume memory
memory for
the compound assembler
and the
associated bookkeeping data.
That depends on how much code
you actually run.
But,
the object representation
of Python,
of Python objects
is more compact
than PyPy.
So,
the actual amount
of memory consumed
by your heap
tends to be smaller.
Like,
all PyPy objects
are as memory compact
as
see Python objects
using
slots.
Right,
okay.
So,
it's the same optimization
except it's transparent.
Then,
the,
like,
list of only integers
would not allocate
the entire objects.
It would allocate
only small integers.
Then,
the,
the objects
are smaller themselves
because we use
a different garbage collection
strategy.
It's not ref counting.
it's a garbage collector.
Right,
so,
let's talk about
the garbage collector
just for a moment.
Is it a mark and sweep
garbage collector?
This episode
is brought to you
by CodeShip.
CodeShip has launched
organizations,
create teams,
set permissions
for specific team members,
and improve collaboration
in your continuous
delivery workflow.
Maintain centralized control
over your organization's
projects and teams
with CodeShip's
new organizations plan.
And,
as Talk Python listeners,
you can save 20% off
any premium plan
for the next three months.
Just use the code
TALKPYTHON,
all caps,
no spaces.
Check them out
at CodeShip.com
and tell them thanks
for supporting the show
on Twitter
where they're at,
CodeShip.
It's in,
very convoluted
variant of mark and sweep.
Yeah.
It has two generations
of objects,
young objects
and old objects,
and old objects
are mark and sweep,
and young objects
are pointer bump
allocations.
So,
the net effect
is that
if you are having
a lot of small objects
that get allocated
all the time
and forgotten
really quickly,
allocation takes,
like,
on average,
around one CPU
instruction.
It's,
on average,
one,
because it takes,
like,
slightly more,
but then you have
pipelining,
so sometimes
it takes slightly less.
Okay,
do you guys do compaction
and things like that
as well?
No,
but we do
copy old objects
from the young generation
to the old generation.
Then we don't compact
the old generation,
but usually more compact
than your normal setup
where you have
lots of objects
that are scattered
all over the place
because you only
have to deal with objects
that survive minor collection.
Right,
and that's the majority
of objects
that we interact with
all die right away.
Vast majority.
Yeah,
absolutely.
For the most part.
Okay,
yeah,
that's very cool.
One of the things
that is not super easy
in regular Python
is parallelism
and asynchronous programming
and so on.
And you guys have
this thing called
stackless mode.
What's the story
with that?
It's the same thing
as stackless Python.
It gives you
an ability
to have coroutines
that can be swapped out
without an explicit
yield keyword.
So it's not like
Python 3 coroutines.
it's like
normal coroutines
when you can swap them
randomly.
For example,
GEvent uses
I think GEvent
uses stackless mode
for swapping
the coroutines.
Okay,
so you said
that you can get
better concurrency.
Can you kind of describe
speak to that any
or what are your thoughts there?
I personally
don't use stackless
all that much
but the net effect
is that you
you can write code
like with
Python 3 coroutines
without the yield keyword.
So you just call function
then you can swap
the functions
for other things.
It's a bit like
implicit
twisted
where
you don't get
better concurrency
than twisted
but you're not
you don't need
to write your programs
in the style
that twisted requires.
I was going to say
it's just a little more
automatic
and you don't have
to be so explicit
that you're doing
threading.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like the normal
normal threads
especially in Python
where you have the
global interpreter log
they don't scale
all that well
and like the solution
is usually twisted
but twisted requires
you to have
all the libraries
and everything
written twisted aware
which stackless
does not generally
requires.
I don't have
any particular feelings
towards all of that
to be honest.
Sure.
Does it also support
Twisted running on PyPy?
Do you know?
Yeah,
obviously.
Twisted is a Python program.
We had
from the very early days
we had
good contact
with twisted people
and people who use twisted
tend to be from
the same category
as people who use PyPy.
People who have
large running code bases
that are boring
but have problems
because they're
actually huge.
I mean not huge
in terms of code base
but huge in terms
of number
of requests
they serve
and stuff like this.
So they tend
to be
very,
very focused
on how to make
the stuff
work both reliably
and fast.
So for example
like a typical answer
to Python performance
problems
oh just rewrite
pieces in C.
Well that's
that's all
cool if you have
like few
small loops
that you can
rewrite in C
and have everything
fast.
But like
most web servers
are not like this.
If you look at the profile
it's just flat.
It's tons of dictionaries
and things that are
not easy to write
in C.
And C introduces
security problems
like suddenly
dealing in C
with untrusted data
is not that much fun.
No.
So it's definitely
not.
Or even
reliability
right?
Yeah.
So all those
problems.
So Twisted people
tend to write
like Python
better than C
and they've
been very supportive
of PyPy
from the very
first day.
So they
generally
PyPy is running
Twisted
and it's running
Twisted quite fast
for quite a few
years right now.
Yeah that's
excellent.
It seems like
if you have a
problem that
Twisted would solve
you also probably
want to look
into PyPy.
Exactly.
This is like
the same category
of problems
that you're
trying to solve.
Another interesting
stuff about
concurrency
which I guess
I'm slightly
more excited
about is the
software transactional
memory that
Armin Rigo is
working on right
now.
So this is
one of our
fundraisers
just like
NumPy.
Yeah so this
is one of your
three sort of
major going
forward projects
if you will.
Yeah those are
the three
publicly funded
projects.
Right and if
you go to
PyPy.org
right there
on the
right it
says donate
towards
STM
and you
guys have
quite a
bit of
money towards
this project
and so
it's excellent.
What is
software transactional
memory for the
listeners?
There are two
ideas.
First problem
they're related
but not
identical.
First problem
is that Python
has the
global
interpreter
log.
So global
interpreter
log essentially
prevents you
from running
multiple threads
on multiple
cores on one
machine.
So if you
write Python
program and
you write
it multi
threaded it
will only
ever consume
one CPU
which is
not great
if you want
to compute
anything.
So that's
one problem
that STM
is solving
and I'm
going to
explain just
now how
it's solving
it.
But another
problem is
that it's
trying to
provide a much
better model
for writing
programs with
threads.
If you start
using threads
the Python
mutability
model makes
it so hard
to write
correct programs.
you're essentially
running into
problems like
suddenly
okay but I
have to think
who modified
what in what
order and
consider all
the possible
combinations.
Make sure that
every bit of
code that's
going to work
with this
segment of
data is
taking the
right locks
and all that
kind of stuff
that gets
really tricky
to ensure
right?
yeah so
essentially
the
model is
where
if you
write
program in
C
you write
the program
it's all
fine then
you switch
to threading
and you get
performance
immediately
like
your program
if you write
threads correctly
it will run
four times faster
on four cores
or whatever
but
it will
likely
crash
and it will
likely crash
for the next
couple of
weeks
months
years
whatever
you throw
into it
because you
need to get
100%
correctness
back
so
the S-team
works slightly
differently
where you
you essentially
write programs
in a mode
where
it looks like
you put a
gigantic lock
around
everything that
matters in
your program
so you
write one
event loop
and you know
like okay
this loop
will
consume blocks
or whatever
consume some
sort of data
in an unordered
queue
and you can
add to the
queue
in an unordered
way
and then you
put a giant
lock
over like
the whole
processing
if you
write that
sort of
program
with normal
threads
and normal
locks
it will
be correct
but it
won't run
fast
because
everything
will be
giant
inside
the giant
locks
to be more
or less
serial
but all
the complexity
in your
code
of doing
parallelism
anyway
yeah
so
this
STM
stands
for
software
transactional
memory
it means
it works
roughly
like a
database
where you
run
multiple
transactions
and then
if you
don't
touch
the memory
from two
threads
at the
same
time
then
it's
all
cool
and if
you
touch
one of
those
gets
aborted
and reverted
and you
can only
commit a
transaction
if
the
memory
access
was
right
so
if
you
think
again
about
the
model
where
you
have
one
gigantic
log
it means
it will
run
in parallel
optimistically
a few
versions
of the
same
code
on
different
data
and if
they
tend
not to
conflict
if
they can
be
run
serially
in a
sense
like
they
modify
some
global
data
but
not
in a
conflicting
manner
then
you'll
get
parallelism
for free
but if
they do
conflict
every now
and again
then
one of
the guys
gets
reverted
back to
the start
so the
net effect
is that
it looks
like you're
running
stuff
serially
for the
programmer
and you
get
correctness
for free
if you
write it
in a
way
that
that's
naive
then you
won't get
performance
because your
stuff will
collide
all the
time
but then
you can
use
tools
and look
where it
collides
and remove
those
contention
points
and you
get more
and more
performance
which is
almost the
same goal
but the
difference
is that
if you
have
100%
performance
and 99%
correctness
your program
is still
incorrect
and you
can't run
it
if you
have
100%
correctness
and 99%
performance
you're
mostly
good to
go
yeah
would you
rather be
fast and
wrong or
slow and
right
it's sort
of
that you
know
there's a
really
interesting
classification
of those
types of
problems
that you
only see
every
very very
rarely
from the
you know
sort of
some kind
of race
condition
or timing
threading
problem
and I've
heard people
describe those
as Heisen bugs
because
because as you
interact with
a program
trying to
see the
problem
you might
not be
able to
observe it
but if
you're not
looking
all of a
sudden
boom
the
timing
realigns
and it's
a problem
again
they're very
frustrating
so it's
important
to look
at
so that
the
usual
answer
for
those
problems
in
Python
is
just
use
multiple
processes
and using
multiple
processes
works for a
category of
applications
and web
servers tend
to be one
of those
because they
only ever
share data
that's
either
caches
or database
usually
that's
another
process
anyway
like
Redis
or
it's
in a
database
like
Mongo
or
SQL
something
like
that
yeah
so
you
don't
care
but like
there's a
whole
set of
problems
where
this is not
what you
have
you have
data
that's
mostly
not
contentious
but
you still
have to
share it
and work
on it
you can't
afford
to
serialize
and deserialize
and pass
between
processes
and yet
you want
to have
a correct
result
so this
is what
STM
is trying
to address
a set
of problems
that can
be solved
by just
splitting
stuff
into
processes
right
maybe
something
very
computational
or scientific
where it's
iterative
or something
would be
way harder
well
essentially
anything
where
you have
data
that
mostly
does not
conflict
and you
can do
it
in
parallel
but
every now
and again
it's a
big data
set
that you
work on
and every
now and
again
you
tend
to
conflict
like
graph
algorithms
are a
great
example
and you
have this
large
complicated
data
structure
in memory
and most
of the time
you're walking
different parts
of graphs
so you don't
care
but every
now and again
you'll find
contention
on one graph
because two
parts are doing
stuff on the
same node
and then you're
like
that's wrong
and writing
this sort of
stuff using
threads
is really
hard
yeah
so that
has a lot
of promise
do you know
when it
might
start to
show up
as a thing
people can
use
is it
there yet
so it's
already there
to an extent
you can
download the
STM demo
somewhere
and the
STM demo
works
it might
not scale
how you want
it
it might
not work
how you
want
it
but it
should
generally
work
and scale
so the
current version
only scales
to like
two or three
cores
and given
that it
comes at
a quite
hefty cost
of like
1.5
to two
times slower
on each
core
it's not
that useful
so the
next version
will try to
reduce the
overhead of
single core
and improve
the scalability
to more
cores
and then
we'll see
how it
goes
it's going
along quite
well
I would
expect
like
I mean
there are
consecutive
prototypes
that are
usable
to some
extent
like we
managed to
get
some
performance
improvements
running
on multiple
cores
but they
have
20-30%
range
which is
just not
that exciting
but on the
other hand
they were
mostly for
free
which is
again
something
that you
might
what if
I rewrite
no no
the point
is you
don't have
to rewrite
it's
a very
simple
change
and then
you might
get
some
performance
benefit
yeah
that's
fantastic
the other
one of the
other
projects
that you
have
on your
donation
list
is a
major
thing
you guys
are
working
on
is
Pi3k
in
PiPi
what's
that
it's
the
Python 3
implementation
of
PiPi
so
as I
said
before
we
have
various
interpreters
in
PiPi
that are
all
implemented
in our
Python
and one
of those
interpreters
is a
Python 2
interpreter
and one
of those
interpreters
which is
less
complete
is Python 3
interpreter
that supports
like
3.2
by now
so
we need
money
to push
it forward
and help
I guess
too
to push
it forward
to like
3.3
or 3.4
or even
3.5
to bring
it more
up to
speed
one thing
that we
don't do
in
PiPi
is we
don't
debate
the
Python
language
choices
and I
think it
serves
us
well
so
for
example
I
don't
work
much
on
the
Python
interpreter
itself
I
work
a lot
on
the
R
Python
side
of
things
and
most
of
the
improvements
help
all
of the
interpreters
not
just
Python
interpreter
so
I
personally
don't care
if it's
Python 2
or Python 3
the improvements
are all the
same to me
right
that's
great
then you
also
have a
section
towards
general
progress
and
the
last
one
is
NumPy
what are
you
trying to
accomplish
with
that
sprint
or
whatever
you
call
it
so
as I
said
before
the
NumPy
stuff
is we
want to
reimplement
the
NumPy
so the
numeric
part
the
operation
on
arrays
and we
have
a very
exciting
project
for
summer
of
code
that
does
vectorization
so using
SSE
for
NumPy
and then
we want
to integrate
more of
the
have a
way to
call
more of
the
whole
ecosystem
of
numeric
Python
so
scipy
mat
world
lib
all
this
stuff
that's
outside
of
the
scope
so we
want
to
have
the
core
of
NumPy
implemented
in
PyPy
because
those
things
are
too
low
level
to
just
call
external
library
and
then
we
want
to
have
a
way
or
multiple
ways
depending
on
the
setup
to
call
all
the
other
ecosystem
and
this
is
essentially
what
those
goals
are
here
those
are
three
ambitious
and
very
cool
goals
very
nice
well
they've
been
around
for
a
couple
years
I
think
so
we
are
working
towards
them
and
we
have
people
working
right
now
on
all
three
proposals
as far
as I
can
tell
yeah
that's
great
so
one
thing
that
is
related
to
PyPy
that
you've
done
individually
is
the
JIT
viewer
can you
talk
about
that
briefly
so
JIT
viewer
internal
tool
for
visualizing
assembler
and the
intermediate
representation
of
your
Python
program
so
it's
very
useful
for
if
you're
really
interested
how
PyPy
compiles
your
program
you can
look
into
that
so
one
related
project
that
I've
been
working
on
recently
quite
a lot
is
called
VMProf
and
is
a
low
overhead
statistical
profiler
for
Python
or
for
VMs
in
general
but
we're
going
to
start
with
CPython
and
PyPy
so
those
are
tools
that
help
developers
find
their
bottlenecks
in the
code
and
find
how
to
improve
performance
usually
because
if you
can
understand
it
you
can
usually
improve
it
yeah
that's
excellent
yeah
we've
been
talking
a lot
about
how
PyPy
makes
stuff
faster
but
before
you
just
say
well
we're
switching
to
some
new
interpreter
maybe
it
makes
sense
to
think
about
your
algorithms
and
where
they're
slow
and
whether
or not
that
switch
would
even
help
it
really
depends
on
the
situation
sometimes
you
switch
without
thinking
about
it
and
sometimes
it
doesn't
make
sense
and
you
have
to
think
about
it
first
really
depends
on
your
program
and
what
are
you
trying
to
achieve
and
sometimes
you
want
to
switch
look
improve
sometimes
you
want
to
do
both
yeah
well
at
minimum
you
probably
want
to
measure
and
profile
your
definitely
want
to
measure
you
definitely
want
to
know
how
fast
your
application
is
running
before
attempting
anything
it
felt
a little
faster
let's
do
it
exactly
you're
laughing
but
we've
seen
people
like
that
my
application
runs
faster
on
my
local
machine
but
not
on
the
server
okay
how
did
you
benchmark
oh
I
looked
at
the
loading
time
Chrome
like
developer
tools
that's
not
good
enough
usually
that's
like
yes
it might
be
slower
because
your
network
is
slower
I
don't
know
what
your
setup
is
maybe
the
ping
time
is
milliseconds
the
request
time
is
milliseconds
so
geez
it's
really
slow
on the
server
right
awesome
all right
Manja
this is
probably
a good
place
to wrap
up
the
show
this
has
been
such
an
interesting
conversation
I'm
really
excited
about
what
you
are
doing
and
you
know
I
hope
you
keep
going
I
want
to
make
sure
that
people
know
that
the
source
code
is
on
bitbucket
they can
go to
bitbucket.org
slash
pipi
that's the
main repo
the main
way to
contact us
is usually
through
either
mailing
list
or
irc
we
hang
out
on
irc
a lot
it's
hash
pipi
on
free
node
and
we're
usually
quite
approachable
when you
come
with
problems
and
one
interesting
thing
is
if
you
find
your
program
running
slower
on their
pipi
than
c
python
it's
usually
considered
a bug
unless
you're
using
a lot
of
c
extensions
right
so
if
people
run
into
that
maybe
they
should
communicate
with
you
guys
and
they
can
definitely
file a
bug
and
complain
excellent
two
quick
questions
I
typically
ask
people
show
what
what's
your
favorite
editor
how do
you
write
code
during
the
day
I
have
heavily
hacked
emux
actually
that
does
all
kinds
of
weird
stuff
and
I'm
way
more
proficient
with
elisp
than
I
would
ever
want
to
be
actually
a
skill
you
didn't
really
want
to
earn
but
you
you've
done
it
anyway
huh
something
like
that
yeah
and
then
also
what's
a
notable
or
interesting
pypi
package
that
you
want
to
tell
people
about
that's
a
tough
one
for
me
because
I
don't
actually
write
all that
much
Python
code
that's
using
libraries
you can't
import
too much
into the
like
the
core
bits
right
but
definitely
and I
mean
it is
self
promotion
but
definitely
cffi
is
something
that
I
would
recommend
people
to
look
call
c
because
this
is
something
very
low
that
has
been
very
successful
as a
simple
way
to
call
c
that's
cool
and
if
I
was
writing
some
program
in
Python
and
I
had
some
computational
bits
I'd
written
in
c
I
could
wire
them
together
with
cffi
you'll
be
surprised
how
few
people
actually
do
that
most
of
the
time
I
have
this
Python
program
and I
have
this
obscure
c
library
that
accesses
this
weird
device
that
nobody
heard
about
and
I
need
to
call
it
somehow
and
that's
why
you
call
c
the
computational
bits
it's
actually
quite
rare
but
that
would
be
an
option
too
yeah
sure
okay
awesome
and
then
finally
just
you said
that you
do
some
consulting
do you
want to
maybe
talk
a little
bit
about
what
you
do
so
if
people
want
to
contact
you
or
anything
like
that
so
the
website
is
barocksoftware.com
and
essentially
what
we
do
is
we
make
your
Python
programs
run
faster
like
the
same
thing
as
we
do
in
open
source
except
on
the
commercial
side
so
typically
if
your
open
source
software
is
running
too
slow
just
come
to
IRC
and
if
your
commercial
software
is
running
too
slow
we
can
definitely
do
a
contract
with
you
to
make
it
run
faster
yeah
that's
awesome
yeah
so
I'm
sure
people
who
are
having
trouble
might
be
interested
in
checking
that
out
so
great
Machia
this
has
been
super
fun
I've
learned
a lot
thanks
thank you
Michael
have a good
day
yeah
you too
this
has been
another
episode
of
talk
Python
to
me
today's
guest
was
Machia
Falkowski
and this
episode
has been
sponsored
by
Hired
and
Codeship
thank
you guys
for
supporting
the
show
Hired
wants
to help
you
find
your
next
big
thing
visit
Hired.com
slash
Talk Python
to me
to get
five or
more offers
with salary
and equity
presented
right up
front
and a
special
listener
signing
bonus
of
$4,000
Codeship
wants you
to
always
keep
shipping
check
them
out
at
Codeship.com
and thank
them on
Twitter
via
at
Codeship
don't
forget
the
discount
code
for
listeners
it's
easy
Talk Python
all
caps
no
spaces
you can
find
the links
from the
show
at
talkpython.fm
episodes
show
and be
sure to
subscribe
to the
show
open your
favorite
podcatcher
and search
for Python
we should
be right
at the
top
you can
also
find
the
iTunes
and
direct
RSS
feeds
in the
footer
of the
website
our
theme
music
is
developers
by
Corey
Smith
who
goes
by
Smix
you can
hear
the
entire
song
on
talk
python.fm
this is
your host
Michael
Kennedy
thanks for
listening
Smix
take us
out of
here
dating
with my
voice
there's no
norm
that I
can
feel
within
haven't
been
sleeping
I've been
using
lots
of
rest
I'll
pass
the
mic
back
to
who
rocked
it
best
I'm first developers, developers, developers, developers, developers.
Developers, developers, developers, developers, developers.